every year or two i'd like to put a bit
of a recap together to bring us up to
speed
for any new players coming along there
has been quite a bit of story covered
across the two games
and looking at my channel alone there
have been around 140 videos talking
about the division timeline
so this will be a somewhat summarized
picture of the division story so far
but for anyone interested in more detail
i'll have links to the other videos on
screen and in the description
[Music]
following black friday retail's busiest
day of the year a number of people began
getting sick
and it was spreading noticeably fast
initially the symptoms were mistaken for
a severe case of the flu
however when people started dying from
it medical personnel quickly began
investigating
and eventually discovered that it seemed
to be an outbreak of the previously
eradicated
smallpox virus to combat the outbreak
the smallpox vaccine was distributed to
the public
but unfortunately the vaccine was
quickly proven ineffective
and devastatingly things were about to
get a whole lot worse
the city's infrastructure was starting
to break down hospitals were becoming
overloaded
and the new york police force was
struggling to maintain the peace
and a number of gangs of rioters were
starting to carve out their own
territories within the city
eventually the government assembled a
new line of defense hoping to help
maintain order
this group was composed of the police
firefighters
civil volunteers and the national guard
and they were known as the joint task
force
or jtf their job to stop the spread of
the virus
and uphold order within the city
the plan was simple all known infected
individuals would be relocated to the
center of the city
separate from the uninfected and in
order to stop these people from leaving
and mixing with the public
a large wall would be built around the
quarantine area
this way the spread would be contained
and they would be in a better position
to get the appropriate personnel
and bring them in directly to where the
help was needed
but eventually the situation got worse
and more than what the jtf could handle
and the sickness too was starting to
affect their numbers
then one of the private military
contractors brought in to help them keep
the peace
known as the last man battalion cut ties
with the jtf and started taking control
of parts of the city for themselves
and on top of this there were a number
of other hostile factions starting to
rise
like the cleaners and the escaped
convicts known as the rikers
this is when the first wave of the
strategic homeland division agents were
activated
their goal to assist the jtf and regain
control of the city
unfortunately it was too late shortly
after the first wave division agents
were released
into the dark zone the government and
the jtf pulled out
leaving behind supplies medicine weapons
thousands of infected and the first wave
agents
abandoned and cut off from the outside
world many agents succumb to the virus
who were killed off by the growing
hostile factions within the quarantine
zone
the area that would later be known as
the dark zone
in the first wave of division agents
were labelled mia and presumed dead
as a result this is the event that
triggered the second wave to be
activated
their goal was to investigate what
happened to the first wave and assist
the jtf in restoring order to new york
city
the commander in charge along with the
majority of the second wave division
agents
was being flown in by helicopter and was
to assemble themselves just outside of
the hostile zone
but as they were landing they were
unexpectedly struck by an inbound
missile
which caused the helicopter to crash
killing everyone on board
it was now down to just a couple of the
remaining shd agents
to carry out the mission
[Music]
new york city was in a horrific state
and there were a number of rumors
of how the rest of the world wasn't
doing much better either
hostile factions had sectioned off parts
of the city fighting for territory
there were the rikers who'd escaped from
the prison on rikers island
they took advantage of the dwindling
prison staff who were either sick or no
longer turning up to work
once on the mainland their goal was to
wreak as much havoc on society as
possible
the society that had had them locked
away especially authority figures
like the jtf other groups weren't
necessarily born out of hate
the cleaners came about with the best of
intentions they were among the thousands
of civilians left behind in the dark
zone
when the jtf pulled out these were the
workers that were helping the jtf and
keeping the city infrastructure ticking
along
construction workers sanitation janitors
garbagemen truck drivers they were also
heavily involved in the construction of
the quarantine zone wall
but when the jtf suddenly picked up and
left these civilians decided to take it
upon themselves to do what was needed to
contain the virus
and restore order to the streets of new
york and the way that they decided to do
this
is to burn everything that had been in
contact with the virus
contaminated items the bodies of those
who had died
and anyone living that may have become
infected
the lmb or last man battalion are a
private military contractor made up of
u.s military veterans
they were hired by large wall street
companies wanting to protect their
assets
the lmb worked alongside the jtf to
start with but as time went on
they watched the city go from bad to
worse
sick of the indecisive local authorities
and the government's complete lack of
ability to control the situation
the lmb decided it was up to them to
restore order to the city
they broke their contract and cut ties
with the jtf executing an officer in the
process from here
they proceeded to do what they deemed as
necessary to rectify the situation at
hand
second wave agents eventually found that
the source of the virus outbreak came
from new york department store
ables and that the man responsible was a
doctor gordon amherst
their mission was now to locate amherst
and find out what he knows in order to
develop a cure
however the second wave was also about
to make another revelation
it was discovered that the first wave
agents weren't all dead
in fact they were very much alive and
now working against the government
they'd gone rogue
after the government pulled out of the
quarantine zone the first wave agents
were unhappy with how things have been
handled by the jtf
and this is where we're introduced to a
prominent figure in the division
storyline
aaron kina aaron keene was a first wave
agent
who after the abandonment of the
quarantine zone became disillusioned
with the government
its plan to save the city and his role
within the division
keenan disavowed the division and went
rogue his first action after turning
against the government
was to recruit other first wave agents
into his new focus of survival
and power any agents that refused
were killed causing other agents to cut
communications
and go into hiding after forming his
group of rogue agents
kina met up with the commanding officer
of the last man battalion
they agreed to collaborate through a
deal that would benefit them both
kina wanted to use the lmb to assist in
operations to establish dominance over
manhattan
and the lmb wanted access to the
division shade technology
to gain advantage over the other hostile
groups
kina with the lmb launched many
operations against the opposing groups
including the jtf the most notable one
being an attack on a helicopter that was
carrying a division commander that was
in charge of the second wave of division
agents
during his time working with the lmb
kina was also investigating the virus
outbreak
he found that dr gordon amherst was
responsible
kina's investigation led him to dr
vitali trinenko in the russian consulate
who was also researching the virus he
organised some of his rogue agents to
kidnap trunenko
and his research kina then found
amherst's lab
as well as some of the virus samples a
3d dna printer
and amherst notes his plan
is to use trenenco and the samples to
weaponize the virus
and use it to fulfill his belief that
only those who are smart enough
and good enough survive the old rules
laws and governments are gone now
only power and survival matter
it was at this time that amherst was
found
shortly after the outbreak it was
discovered that amherst had fallen to
his own creation
notes and recordings detailed why he did
it
his reason for creating and spreading
the virus was that humanity was too
powerful on a global scale
and mother nature needed help in
advancing her creations
mankind is the greatest threat to the
survival of the planet
through their own greed but he had the
cure
amherst had a darwinist point of view
only the strong deserve to live
and his creation is the tool to ensure
that this happens
but at the same time he is willing and
accepted that his death
may come from his own creation
he was able to modify the basic smallpox
virus by combining it with several other
dangerous diseases
like ebola and h1n1 on top of this he
also modified the genetic traits that
controlled the incubation period
and made it so that it could spread even
whiles incubating in the host
this made it particularly lethal because
by the time the host was showing
symptoms
it had already spread to a significant
number of others
using a protein printer amherst was able
to create the final form of this virus
just in time for black friday his plan
was to spread this new virus by means
that were most handled during the
shopping holiday
money hence the name the dollar flew
[Music]
slowly the second wave division agents
and the jtf were able to push back the
hostile factions and regain control of
the city
the rikers and cleaner leadership was
taken care of crippling their advances
the lmb were pushed back into their
final stronghold located in the united
nations building
during the lengthy battle kena betrays
the lmb and escapes with trininko and
his fellow rogue agents
the lmb is left to slowly be taken apart
by the division agents
it was later discovered that keener had
spent some time on the west side pier
at this stage all hostile groups had
feuds against him
most of all the lmb he broadcasted his
location
to bring all hostile factions to the
area to hunt him down
which in turn brought the jtf and the
division agents whose distraction helped
keep the hostile groups from finding him
he also taunted the division agents
stating that no one would ever find him
and despite the quarantines and
lockdowns of the island he'll soon be
gone
this time it's now confirmed that aaron
kina is long gone from manhattan
in new york city altogether there is
confirmation that kina is
or was in washington but he continues to
leave messages for the jtf and other
government agents to convince them of
his ways and beliefs
and to join him and his agents in
working against the government
his final message was to inform the
division that his eyes are not just set
on the united states
but now the world
seven months have passed since the green
poison outbreak and the events that
unfolded in new york city
division agents have continued on with
their mission of saving what remains
across the united states when suddenly
their lifeline was severed the shd
network
the backbone of their advanced
technology and communications
goes dead quickly followed up by the
backup protocol of a distress call that
summons all agents to the nation's
capital
washington dc agents from outside of dc
make their way to the capital fighting
their way through the city they come
across what remains
of the city's joint task force who have
set up their base of operations in the
white house
shd coordinators on site fill in the
agents of what's happening throughout
the city
three hostile factions are fighting for
control the hyenas
a group that is composed of several
gangs who have come together as one
under the leadership of a council to
take advantage of the chaos that is
unfolding
the outcasts a group made up of
survivors of the roosevelt island
quarantine zone
their goal to enact revenge on those
responsible for their mistreatment and
to the society that allowed it to happen
and the true sons a powerful group of
xjtf who have lost faith in the
government's ability to bring control to
the situation at hand
the division agents get to work finding
the fault to restore the shd network
but before they can achieve this new
information comes to light
somewhere in the city there may in fact
be a cure to the virus that started it
all
but also that the previously assumed
dead president ellis
may have survived the crash of air force
one
while clearing out areas through the
city the agents find intel
on ellis's whereabouts and that he's
being held captive by the hyenas
the division managed to clear the
hostiles and extract him via helicopter
back at the white house alice confirms
that there is in fact a cure
but not just for the green poison but
all viral infections
however he is unable to access it
without his briefcase
and this was on air force one when it
went down
the briefcase was in the possession of
the true sons and they were holding it
in their hq
at the u.s capitol building president
ellis ordered the agents to do what it
takes to cleanse the city of these
hostile forces
and return his briefcase however the
division wasn't strong enough to be able
to tackle this challenge just yet
first things first they located the
fault in the network and restored power
to the strategic homeland division
and their agents from here they set
forth clearing the hostiles
and pushing them back to their
respective strongholds
upon removing the hyenas from district
union arena
the outcasts from roosevelt island and
then the true sons from the u.s capitol
building
the division has now eliminated all
hostile leadership leaving the factions
in a state of disarray
but also they had found alice's
briefcase
while the agents and the jtf celebrated
their progress towards regaining the
control of the capital
a force that had been lurking in the
shadows suddenly made themselves known
the technologically advanced private
military company called the black tusk
launched a full invasion of the city
landmarks and strategic points
throughout the city were quickly brought
under black tusk control
and it was during this time that
president ellis suddenly disappeared
it was revealed that the black tusk had
been watching the progress of the dollar
flu outbreak for some time
including the actions of the strategic
homeland division
division agents soon found out that it
was this new hostile force that was
responsible for the shd network being
taken down
and that they had been planning this
invasion since the outbreak first
occurred
the black tusk had in very quick
succession completely undone all of the
progress that the division had made up
until now
unwavered the agents against all odds
once again
thought through it was discovered that
president ellis had actually handed over
the antivirals to the black tusk
and that they had been working together
and in fact had something to do with the
death of the last president
that had him put in power the antivirals
were being held at the black tusk tidal
basin headquarters
the agents launched an attack and
managed to fight through the
technologically superior forces
regaining control of the antivirals
washington dc
is once again in a state of mayhem with
three original hostile factions
although without the original leaders
fighting for control
and now a new more powerful faction
attempting to establish a new dynasty
to lead the country into a new era
president ellis was located he was found
to be hiding out
at the presidential retreat camp white
oak
heavy guard by the black tusk forces the
jtf and the division
assault the compound in an attempt to
arrest alice and bring him back for
questioning
unfortunately before they could reach
him he managed to escape
his whereabouts are currently unknown
the division agents then turned their
attention to the pentagon
they have received a transmission from
an agent close by this agent was
scouting the darpa labs
to see if they had succeeded in
developing a perfusion bioreactor
with this device they will be able to
produce large quantities of the broad
spectrum antivirals
and start to distribute them across the
population
however they weren't the only ones
looking for it a large-scale black tusk
operation was underway
they were attempting to dig down through
the pentagon and extract the bioreactor
but the division agents managed to put a
stop to this in turn killing dozens of
black tusk officers
the perfusion bioreactor is now being
kept to the white house
along with the broad-spectrum antivirals
the next step towards creating the cure
requires the agent to find someone
capable of running such an undertaking
so on with experience in this field
the division receives intel on the
whereabouts of a former agent
who is at the top of their most wanted
list aaron kina has finally resurfaced
after disappearing months ago
last seen in new york city keener has
made a deal with the black tusk unit
that is stationed on coney island
he is planning on trading vitali
trunenko in exchange for a favor that
he'll call upon at a later date
trinenko is a virologist that had ties
to the creator of the dollar flu
dr gordon amherst the division saw this
as a great opportunity
keener is the man behind countless
deaths of jtf and shd agents
and the leader of the initial rogue
agent uprising entreneco
would be the perfect candidate to run
the bioreactor
this situation was too good to let it
slip by
away they could be running into a trap
the division launched an operation to
rescue trenenco
and capture kinah despite heavy black
tusk presence they managed to extract
the russian scientist
to their surprise an old foe joined the
fight the cleaners
the black tusk suffered heavy losses at
the hands of both the cleaners and the
division agents
they were forced to retreat
a distress call was received from the
division command in lower manhattan
city hall has been attacked agents from
washington make their way to new york
through video surveillance it is found
that a group of rogues led by aaron kina
were the ones responsible
the attack left the building completely
destroyed and contaminated
by a new unknown virus that keena had
acquired from vitali trinenko before
they parted ways
the hunt for arakina was on
the division agent set up a base in a
local sediment called haven
where the local commanding agent fei lau
got to work compiling clues on kina's
whereabouts
with all that had happened over the last
few months in new york with countless
once loyal agents going rogue
faith in the division was an all-time
low
agents would have to regain the trust of
the remaining population if they were to
succeed
one by one the agents located and
eliminated kina's rogue lieutenants
through each encounter they found new
clues and intel on kina's whereabouts
including his plans to reset society
keener had set himself up on liberty
island his plan was to launch a
ballistic missile that was filled with
his new weaponized virus
on manhattan the agents board a ferry
and make their way to liberty island but
before they make it there
they are attacked by the black tusk who
have also learned of kina's location
and are trying to get to him before the
division does
they seek ground forces to stop kinah
including a marauder-class quadcopter
and warhounds but the division agents
managed to push through
and overwhelm their forces it was now
just the agents
and kina even with this new more
advanced shd tech
keen was no match for the division
agents they managed to destroy the
missile launcher containing the virus
and heavily wound kinah he escaped to
the pair
but his injuries proved too much the
division agents caught up to him and
before they could stop him he activated
something on his watch
something he called his legacy
with his dying breaths he laughed at the
agents telling them they have no idea
what's coming
before dying shortly after it was
at this time broadcasted through kena's
watch that the division discovered that
the acting commander of the division in
new york
feylau had gone rogue and was working
with the black tusk
before the events at city hall kenyard
spent some time recruiting
he was building an army of rogue agent
cells each tasked with their own mission
this group of rogues were all aligned
through kina's own version of the shd
network
called anna
[Applause]
the first cell was headed by an agent
going by the call sign
jupiter with her team of rogues
supported by the cleaners
running a distraction in washington dc
she was able to secure a newly developed
emp technology from cargo plane that had
crashed on roosevelt island
this new technology was able to
neutralize all non-rogue shd tech and
completely remove an agent's armor
jupiter's mission was to capture this
tech get it operational
and ship it out to all rogue agents
nationwide
this would [ __ ] the remaining shd
agents around the country
however the division was able to
overwhelm her forces and react faster
than jupiter was prepared for
on roosevelt island she ordered the
cleaners to utilize all available emp
jammers
to put a stop to the fast approaching
agents but it was too late
the division pushed through the defenses
destroying the mps
and found themselves face to face with
jupiter and eventually
after a long battle the agents put a
stop to her plans
killing her in the process
unfortunately for the division this
would be just the first
of a potentially large number of rogue
cells that the division would face
in the months to come having technically
already died once before
one of kena's lieutenants from earlier
on in the conflict is back
and more loyal to keena's cause than
ever
hornet kina's most trusted agent is
leading a sale of rogues to fulfill his
legacy
once in dc hornets set forth with
recruiting
he saw the outcasts as a good place to
start since they're currently leaderless
and in need of a purpose but they aren't
exactly friendly to strangers
but he had a different way of getting
their attention
after demonstrating the power of kina's
eclipse virus the outcasts were more
than happy to throw in their support
as per kina's instructions hornet set up
at tidal basin with his new army of
outcasts
he was responsible for continuing the
production of the eclipse virus
and getting them ready to be sent out
across the country
but the loss of his team of rogues meant
that the division was quickly able to
locate him
the division assaulted the compound
bonnet instructed the outcasts
to put a stop to the agent advances
while the eclipse virus was being loaded
into a hovercraft
but the agents caught up with them
quickly dealing to the outcasts
and destroying the samples on board
hornet launched an attack on the
division
however they proved too much they were
able to bring him down
and eliminate him this time for good
time and time again the black tusk have
been hindering the strategic homeland
division's attempts
at regaining control of the nation's
capital so it's finally time to remove
the btsu leader from the equation
but now thanks to feylau he has a number
of ex-division agents working with them
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in lower
manhattan and dc
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
eliminate them but these agents were
very obviously a distraction
so barden schaefer could continue his
operation on coney island
it was around this time that the
division were able to intercept a comms
between baden
and someone called natalia sokolova it
isn't clear who natalya is to barton
but she's certainly the one calling the
shots she could be someone further up
the chain within the black tusk
or maybe the main contact for the
organization that has employed them
natalia ordered baden to clean up his
mess and finish the job
he instructed his group of elite btsu
operatives to assemble
and prepare for the fast approaching
division agents
in a final offensive push barton took
the fight to the agents
and although he was strong and put up a
formidable resistance
they eventually managed to take him down
barton was critically injured but not
killed
a halo was sent to retrieve him where he
would be brought back to health
and questioned on his knowledge around
the black tusk and the organization who
has employed them
feylau was one of the division's most
trusted agents
however her mission to avenge the death
of her sister and rid the world of aaron
kina
led her to going rogue and joining the
black tusk
although still apprehensive of her
decision to join up with the black tusk
faye meets up with barden schaefer to
discuss plans going forward
over time schaefer was eventually hunted
down by her former colleagues
and captured but faye took little time
in organising a meeting with president
ellis
after finding out alice's whereabouts
and schedule faye caught up with them at
camp white oak
and when the time came without
hesitation she gunned him down where he
stood
at this point in time division agents
were already hot on a trail
but faye had already rang through
announcing that it was the division who
had taken up the president
so time was of the essence they needed
to catch up with her before they too
were announced as rogue
chasing her through the compound they
eventually caught up with her in the
area that alice himself
had once escaped their grasp but this
time
they were prepared disabling the
helicopter
faye was forced to engage the agents
head on
after a short fight the division was
able to eliminate her supporting btsu
forces
although faye certainly brought the
fight the shd agents had no problem
bringing the full force of their
vengeance to the party
and this about sums up everything that's
happened in the division up until now
but the story is far from over although
the division have managed to stop a
number of black tusk operations
and have captured or killed a lot of
their leadership up until this point it
has barely slowed their movements and
then there is the organization behind
the btsu
being led by natalya sokolova while the
black tasks have the troops on the
ground
it's this organization who's calling the
shots
the division two are themselves in a
very bad place at the moment
most of their agents have either been
killed or have turned rogue
those who still remain loyal to the shd
made to be flagged as rogue after the
assassination of the president who up
until this point
was one of the last remaining officials
of the old government
there is considerably more depth to a
number of these stories and i'll have a
link to most of them in the description
i've been talking about it for a while
but now might be the time for me to do
that video of the full story
spanning the two games where i cover all
the details
given that this could be a two three or
even four hour plus video
it pains me to think of how long and how
many energy drinks i would need to
record this
anyway i hope you found this informative
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]